leute ich will jetzt auch so ein cooler
rapper und hat mir eine bauchtasche
gekauft habe ich auch schon neue sachen
drin verstaubt wie beispielsweise
allerdings herzlich willkommen jetzt
meine damen und herren zum heutigen
video ihr seht es bereits im titel 2015
das heutige video wird nämlich eine art
airbag sein
wie oft habe ich eigentlich auf diesen
fakten tisch im jahr 2015 bestand meinen
youtube-kanal schlichtweg eigentlich nur
aus drei verschiedenen spielen und zwar
akinator clever bord und agrio und daher
hab ich mir gedacht dass wir heute diese
drei spiele einfach mal hintereinander
spielen wir fangen mit dem lieben clever
bord und zwar mich bereits geschrieben
hallo daraufhin er wort darauf endlich
wieder was geht ab nicht viel bei dierig
daraufhin cool und er magst du in dir
beste website aller zeiten ich war noch
nie dort punkt punkt punkt ist es meist
als ich war noch nie in indien ich auch
noch nicht wollen wir zusammen hinreisen
frage ich ihn einfach mal nein ich habe
einen schock erinnert mich so ein
bisschen an meine movistar planet video
letzte woche habe ein freund ich habe
auch eine freundin schreibe ich dann
einfach mal also wenn er ein freund hat
okay ich dachte du bist ein mädchen also
erstmal können noch mädchen eine
freundin haben aber nein ich bin ein
junger neben glaube ich ein junge leute
wollen wir heiraten ist klar dass selbst
bruder ich liebe dich küste deine brust
also kannst du gerne küssen dasteht
luxury meter drauf ein wunderschönes t
shirt das ist vor einer woche gelaunt
stehen
aber fragen wir doch einfach mal den
clever bot er den luca - shop.de
überhaupt kennt kennst du den luca
shop.de frage ich einfach mal das würde
mich echt mal interessieren was ist
deine lieblingsprodukt frage ich dann
einfach mal da bin ich jetzt echt mal
gespannt ich habe keins du findest alle
toll frage ich mal also wenn er kein
lieblingsprodukt hat nennen wir mal ein
paar luxus schreibe ich einfach mal das
ist ja das was ich gerade an habe okay
dann nur einer und damit würde ich sagen
müssen wir uns auch direkt in das zweite
der drei spiele die ich heute
vorbereitet habe und zwar mio
da geht es darum dass ich dieser ball
hier bin und kleinere bälle fressen muss
und dadurch wachse ich kann jetzt
beispiel ihm hier vorne auffressen und
dadurch werde ich größer ich kann aber
auch diese anderen kleinen welle hier
fressen ich kann mich auch splitten dann
bin ich quasi zwei personen und bin ein
bisschen schneller unterwegs ich glaube
falls ihr schon ein paar jahre abonnent
von meinem kanal seit er kennt ihr noch
die ak rio zeit und zwar meine videos ja
da millionen aufrufe gemacht ist ob ich
hatte sogar mehrere addario videos über
drei millionen aufrufe gemacht haben ja
ja
es war auf jeden fall eine mega mega
krasse zeit und deswegen habe ich mir
halt gedacht hey wenn ich jetzt heute
sonst rohbeck video machte harald hin
aufgefressen wenn ich jetzt heute schon
sonst robert video mache dann kann muss
ich auf jeden fall auch addario spielen
ich bin nämlich schon platz 15
das klingt tatsächlich ziemlich schnell
30 nochmal ihn hier vorne auf zack ihnen
hier vorne das bitte ich mich mal eben
da bin ich wieder platz 17 jetzt relativ
schnell geworden agrarius ist natürlich
nicht so ein spiel wie clever dort wo
man direkt auf jede aussage eigentlich
die zeit rapide sondern eher so ein
spiel muss man wirklich so lange lagern
kann und den hier vorne was ich auch
noch mal eben auf wir sind auf platz
acht vorgestoßen freunde ich habe gerade
ein paar mehr gefertigt platz sechs
worte [ __ ] wie schnell geht das denn
dann versuche ich jetzt noch mal schnell
den tommi aufzufressen den anderen auch
noch ich bin platz vier auf platz sechs
ist ihr name mich willst auf jeden fall
mal kasse interessieren
weshalb ihr eventuell meinen kanal
abonniert habe wir sind übrigens platz
drei es könnte jetzt gerade
es ist gerade richtig interessant
freunde und mein gott nein nein
[Musik]
das doch nicht wahr
gut kommen wir jetzt zum letzten spiel
und zwar akinator beim akinator geht es
darum dass wir an eine person denken
müssen und dieser typ hier stellt uns
fragen in bezug auf unsere personen wir
müssen diese fragen beantworten und er
versucht so schnell wie möglich auf
unsere person zu kommen das heißt ich
denke mal an mich und wir schauen ob er
mich noch kennen es trägt deine figur
weibliche kleidung unisex ist das kann
schon ein technisches problem ist
aufgebracht hat super geklappt daten war
die ganze scheiße einfach mal von vorne
und zwar ist seine figur weiblich nein
ich bin nicht weit weg ist eine figur in
deutschland geboren ja ich wurde auch
durch youtube berühmt ich spiele auch
minecraft denken wow die früchte frage
ja der kanal meiner figur heißt konnte
liga du musst es ist in meinem kanal es
kann doch nur ich sein mach deine figur
drei sportarten wie yoga ich glaube
schon dass ich drei verschiedene
sportarten mache ich schreibe wohin noch
bin ich in deutschland geboren und jetzt
komme ich aus der ukraine auf einmal
wenig kommt nicht aus der ukraine hat
eine figur spitze eckzähne
ich glaube ich hab ganz normale zähne
oder ich komme auch nicht aus finnland
sie ja ich spiele auch nicht bei
minecraft flucht mit was auch immer das
ist mag denn ich wollte ja ich liebe
oldtimer hat er nicht gehört was mit
lukas ja ich bin voll andermal luca an
der stelle wird das sollte ich jetzt
alles am ende meiner lieben freunde wenn
euch dieses roberg ins jahr 2015
gefallen hat dann das gerne einen daumen
hoch unter diesem video jeder abonniert
main kanal falls ihr wollt dass ich
öfter akinator algari oder clever bord
hochladen vielleicht auch mal wieder
gott simulator das war halt einfach die
zeit auf einem kanal vor vier jahren wo
ich jeden zweiten tag diese spieler
eigentlich gebracht habe und komplett
durch gezockt habe mehr oder weniger ich
war das video heute auf jeden fall mega
mega lights total nostalgisch irgendwie
auch so ein bisschen also wie bereits
gesagt wird es euch gefallen hat würde
ich mich sehr aber eine positive
bewertung von euch freuen das t shirt
hier gibt es in lugano shop.de den link
dazu findet ihr unter der beschreibung
und jetzt kommt's drauf
[Musik]